[MUSIC PLAYING - AMBIENT
ELECTRONIC]
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to this installment of
Chrome Apps Office Hours here
on Google Developers Live.
I'm Joe Marini.
I'm the lead developer advocate
here on the Chrome
Apps team, and today we're
going to be talking about
inter-app messaging using Chrome
apps and extensions.
So before I get started, if you
have any questions about
what I'm about to show you today
you can, of course, feel
free to shout them
at your screen.
But if you want the question to
actually be answered, you
should probably post it on our
Google Developers G+ channel
or leave it in the YouTube
comments, and we'll try to get
to as many questions
as we can.
All right, so let's go ahead
and get started.
I'm going to show you a
demo before I actually
jump into some code.
So here I've got my Chrome
browser running.
I'm going to go ahead and open
up a new tab, and I'm going to
start up a couple of sample
apps that I've built.
And actually, before I do that,
if you want to follow
along with me, you're more
than free to do so.
Jump on over to our
GitHub repo.
If you go to the
GoogleChrome/chrome-app-samples
repo here on Git and you scroll
on down, you'll see
this guy right here,
"Messaging." That's the sample
app that I'm going to
be using today.
So you can go ahead and fire
up the code and play along
with me at home if you like.
All right, so back to
the sample apps.
I'm going to scroll down.
Now I have loaded these as
unpacked apps, so these are
not installed from the
Chrome Web Store.
I've just loaded
them unpacked.
So I'm going to start up
Messaging App number one, and
that's this guy right here.
And I'll just move them over so
we can fit both of them on
the screen.
Scale it down just a little,
and now I'll open up the
second one, and that's
Messaging App
number two right here.
OK, so now I've got two
applications open.
So what I'm going to do now
is show these two apps
communicating with each
other by sending
messages to one another.
And the scenario here is that
you've got one or more Chrome
apps that want to communicate
with each other, and you can
do that by sending messages.
And this also works
for extensions.
There's a pretty common
use case.
I've seen questions like this
on the forum or talks I've
given where people say, hey,
I've got an extension,
building a Chrome app.
It would be nice if they could
communicate with each other.
And that's what this feature
allows you to do.
Now just to be clear, this is
not the same thing as opening
a channel from an extension
into a content
script in the web page.
The concept is the same, but the
API is slightly different.
This is about sending
self-contained individual
messages from extensions to apps
or apps to extensions or
apps to apps.
It's not about opening a
long-lived socket-ish port
kind of connection so that
things can communicate.
So with that out of the way,
let me show you the demo.
So back over here in app one,
you can see that it's telling
me what its app ID is.
This is an important part
of the process.
I have to have the ID so that I
know which app I'm going to
be communicating
with and from.
So I'm going to copy that ID
and, over here, I'm going to
paste that ID into
this field here.
And then I'm going to put a
little message in there.
I'm going to say, "Hello app!"
And I'm going to click the
Send button.
And you can see over here in
the first app, I got my
message, and it says, from
this ID I got the
message, hello app.
And in the sending application
it says that I sent the
message, and I got a response
back, and the response is just
some JSON object saying, hey,
the result was, OK, we got
your message.
And now that I've got that
connection open, I can go
ahead and copy this ID, put it
in over here, say, "thanks for
the message," and click Send.
And you can see that I'm sending
messages to and from
each application.
And just to show you that it
works with extensions as well,
I'm going to go over here and
move this out of the way.
And in my Chrome browser, I've
installed the sample extension
that comes along with this code
sample, and you can see
that the UI pretty much
looks the same.
Clearly I'm an engineer, not a
designer, so let's just put
that aside for the moment.
But let's go ahead and send
a message from the
extension to the app.
So you can see here I've got my
extension ID, and we'll use
that in a second when we send
a message to the extension.
But for the current example,
let's go back to Messaging
App1, or Messaging
App2, I guess.
I'm going to copy this ID, I'm
going to go to the extension,
paste the ID in, and send
it a message saying,
hello from the extension.
I'll click Send, and you can
see that it's acknowledging
that the message was sent.
I got a response back saying,
result OK, got your message.
Well, let's see if
it actually did.
Let's go to app two.
And you can see right here it
says, from this ID, hello,
from the extension.
OK, so now let's send a message
to the extension.
So let's go back
to the browser.
I'm going to bring the extension
up, I'm going to
copy its ID, and I'm going to
go back to the app, and this
time I'll paste the
ID in here.
And the message I'll send is,
hello extension from the app,
and I'll click send.
Now, in this particular case,
I've implemented the sample to
show a notification that is
going to pop up in the upper
corner of my screen.
So pay attention, I'm going to
click Send, and you can see
that I've got a little
notification popping up there.
That's the extension
acknowledging that it got the
message and using the
notification's API to display
the message.
All right, so this all
looks fine and great.
Let's jump over to the code to
see how it actually works.
And actually, before I jump to
the code, let me show you
really quickly the API that
we're going to be talking
about today.
So in the documentation for
Chrome apps, if you go to
Developer.Chrome.com/apps, and
I'm going to scroll on down to
the Chrome JavaScript APIs
link right here.
Click on that.
And I'm going to scroll
on down to runtime.
Click on runtime.
So this is the namespace we'll
be using, and we're going to
be using the sendMessage method
right here, and we'll
also be using the
onMessageExternal event.
So let me jump on down to the
sendMessage API, and you can
see that the sendMessage
API is pretty simple.
It takes an extension ID or
well, an app ID as well, and
that's optional.
If you don't provide that, then
the message will simply
go to the origin of whatever
the message was.
Which can be useful, if you want
to just send messages to
yourself, that's fine as well.
But that's where we provide the
string that represents the
ID of the target
of the message.
The message here is the second
parameter, and that can be
pretty much anything.
It has to be a JSON-ifiable
object, and that's usually
what it is, and that's the
demo I'll be showing you.
And then there's an optional
responseCallback.
So if you want to get a response
from the target of
the message, you can fill in
this callback function, and it
will be called when the receiver
of the message calls
a corresponding function saying,
hey I got the message,
and everything seems
to be fine.
All right, so I'm going to jump
over to Sublime, and this
is the sample.
You can see I've opened the
folder up here in Sublime.
So let's take a quick tour
of the source code.
So in app one, and the code for
app one and app two are
pretty much the same, so I'll
just go through one of these.
You can see that here's the
HTML for the UI, pretty
straightforward.
If we look in the manifest file,
you'll notice that there
are no special permissions
needed to take advantage of
this feature.
You can just send messages
all you want.
You don't have to specify any
particular permission for your
app to be able to do this.
In the main.js file, pretty
simple once again, we've got a
launched listener for when our
app launches, sets up the main
app window.
All the magic happens here in
the index.js file for the
application.
So let me scroll down so
you can see the code.
So in the UI, I have a Send
button, and on the Send
button, I'm setting up an event
listener right here to
listen for the click.
And inside the click handler,
all I need to do is call
Chrome.runtime.sendMessage.
And you can see that I've got
that edit field for where the
ID was entered, and so I get
the value of that field,
that's the ID of the target.
And then here's the JSON object
that I'm using to send
the message.
So in this case, I have
a property called
myCustomMessage and whatever
the value of
the text field was--
I can make this as complex
as I like--
and then I've got a
function here for
handling the response.
And all that's doing is just
calling some function I wrote
to stick some HTML into
that div that you see
there on the page.
And that's pretty much how
you send the message.
So you have to know the person
you're sending the message to,
you've got the message you want
to send, and then the
optional response.
Let me scroll down a
little bit more.
OK, here's how the message gets
handled when it comes in.
So again, on the runtime
name space, I have the
onMessageExternal event, and I'm
just adding a listener to
that event.
And the handler function
for this event
does a couple of checks.
First, I've got a variable here
called blacklistedIDs.
So if you have a set of sources
that you know you
don't want to receive messages
from, or, on the other hand,
if you want to just have a list
of known targets that you
want to receive messages from,
you can set that up in advance
and check to see if the ID of
the incoming message is only
one that you want to handle.
So this code is just saying,
hey, is the sender ID inside
this list of blacklisted IDs.
And I could flip this around,
I could do it so that it's
only inside a white-listed
set of IDs.
Then I send the response saying,
hey, sorry I couldn't
process the message.
Go bug somebody else.
Otherwise, I'd check to see if
the incoming request has a
property called myCustomMessage.
So that way, I know that the
message is in a format that I
know how to handle.
And if it is, then all I'm doing
here is calling some
code that just puts some
information inside that result
area that shows the sender
ID and the value
of the custom message.
And then I send back a response
saying, hey, the
result is I got your message.
And you can see that the message
I'm sending back is a
JSON object.
And again, this is optional.
This will be sent back to the
caller when the message
receiving is completed.
Otherwise, if the request coming
in doesn't have the
myCustomMessage property, then
I say, no idea what you're
talking about.
Sorry, you must think
I'm somebody else.
So the handler function takes
in the request, it tells me
who the sender was, and I've
got this little callback
function right here called
sendResponse.
SendResponse is just the
function that sends the
response back to the caller.
All right, let's go ahead
and take a look at
the extension code.
And what you'll notice is that
the extension code is pretty
much the same.
The difference here is that--
well, actually, there's not
much of a difference.
It's basically calling the same
send message function
that the app uses, so
the API is the same.
The only real difference is
that inside the event page
that I have for my extension,
I'm using the WebKit
notifications API to create
a desktop notification
indicating that I received
the incoming message.
And so I've got the same handler
right here on the
runtime namespace, so
add event listener
onMessageExternal, and now I
have a way to communicate
messages both to and from apps
as well as extensions.
Not terrible rocket science,
pretty straightforward, really
easy way for your apps and
extensions to communicate with
each other.
Just one API that you need to
know for sending messages,
just one event handler that
you need to know about for
receiving messages, and it's
pretty straightforward.
So I think if we have any
questions, we can take them
now, otherwise I will see you
again at our next installment
of Chrome Apps Office Hours.
Please feel free to hit us up
on our Google+ G+ channel if
you have any questions.
If you think of any after the
show is over, I monitor the
channel all the time, or you can
hit me up personally, Joe
Marini, also on G+ and I
will see you online.
Thanks very much
for joining me.
Hope you enjoyed this
installment.
Now go out and build some
connected apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING - AMBIENT
ELECTRONIC]